Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, Rawkode.
Today is the episode of Rawkode Live, the
show where we take a look at cloud
native Kubernetes
and fund development projects to help make your
lives a little bit easier.
And today, we're tackling source control security posture,
which is gonna be a whole lot of
fun. Of course, I am not smart enough
to get this conversation, but I am joined
by someone who is.
Hello. Barak from Scribes Security. How are you?
I'm great. I'm actually very happy to join
you for this episode.
Yeah.
Awesome. Well, thank you for taking the time
to join me and, you know, do some
live experimentation
with an open source project called the GitGat.
But before we talk about that, can you
tell our audience a little bit more about
you?
Well, of course. I mean, you know, I'm
I'm just not a I'm not just a
pretty face.
Like you said, my name is Rawkode.
I'm currently working as the developer advocate for
Scribe Security, a company that deals with software
supply chain security.
Other
than that, I can say that before Scribe,
I was a developer on and off for
about ten years. I have a degree in
art education,
a bit unusual in the field, I know.
And other than explaining complicated concepts clearly,
I'm also a dad.
I'm a sci fi and fantasy nerd. I'm
a martial arts instructor, and I'm a dungeon
master. So I'm a, you know, well rounded
individual.
You can actually see some of my swords
in the background.
Nice.
I I think it's always great that, you
know, technology welcomes everybody from regardless of their
background. Although you may be the first art
major that I've I've had a conversation with.
I am not great. Yeah. Education art major.
So the education part is the education part
is very useful. The art, slightly less.
Yeah.
I'm I'm not creative at all. I often
say if I have to build a UI
for something, it's gonna be black text on
a background. And that to me, that that
that's good enough.
However, thank you for joining us. So thank
you for sharing all that as well.
Do you wanna tell us a little bit
more about
describe and get and, you know, everything in
between?
Of course.
Well, like, I'll I'll try to keep this
part at least the the Stripe part short
because GitGuard is is our focus here, and
I don't wanna take too much away from
that. Stripe security, like I said, is is
dealing with software supply chain security.
If you don't know what that is, software
supply chain is the idea that everything,
all the code, all the tools that you
use are interconnected,
and one
weak link
is enough to create
an extensive
blast radius.
Some of the
one of the most common examples in the
field is
is the breach
that happened at the end of
twenty twenty, SolarWinds.
Yep. One little
well, I wouldn't quite say mistake, but one
little change in the code exposed over 18,000
computers, lots of damages.
It's
as a result from that, a lot of
regulatory
changes happened. Scribe is right there to help
companies
secure the software supply chain, gain more visibility
and trust into whatever code they're doing, including
getting the the the provenance of the code,
including making sure that stuff wasn't modified or
changed where it's not supposed to,
you're more than welcome I mean, I'm saying
to our viewers, you're more than welcome to
check out the Stripe security website.
It's there's a freemium level, you can try
it out.
And you can also, you know, contact me
either on LinkedIn or my email for with
any questions you might have. That's about Scribe.
And, again, I can talk about Scribe a
lot more, but this is about GitGat.
And GitGat is an open source project that
was created by Scribe
with the focus on SCM
security posture. Now SCM, for those of you
who don't know the the abbreviation,
is source control the source code management. So
the most common source
code management platform out there is GitHub, and
I'm sure almost every single one of our
listeners knows GitHub. But there are others out
there. You probably know them, like GitLab or
Bitbucket.
There's a few more of them. At least
big ones, there's quite a few more less
well known ones.
And the idea behind GitGat is that
a lot of these platforms
were designed, first and foremost, to enable easy
sharing of information,
enabling lots of people to work together on
code.
Obviously, when you get a lot of people
to work together on code, security is not
always at the top of the list.
Developers,
most of them being lovely, trusting people, don't
always consider the fact that some of them
are not as nice and are mainly interested
in stealing code or modifying it.
Again, the idea behind GitGap is to hand
you a report about your security posture, either
of your private GitHub account or if in
case you're an organization
with a GitHub account about your organizational
security posture. It involves quite a few things,
and I will go over them in the
report. The nice things about GitGat is, first
of all, if you learn about GitGat, you
know about the security posture so you can
handle it yourself if you want to. Secondly,
that report is private. You generate the report
once or continuously.
All the results that you get are only
yours. Nobody else sees them, unlike, for example,
scorecard,
which is public. Once you generate the scorecard
for your repository,
everybody can see it. So Gitcat is private,
and you can add quite a few little
things to it built into it, of course.
So you can you could just configure them.
For example, you can use a state to
manage exactly what information you get on a
continuous manner. You can add information
to your state, for example, like,
you can set
approved
modifiers or or contributors,
people that if they happen to touch or
accounts, actually, that if they happen to touch
your code, you'll be alerted for it. There's
lots of nifty new things that you can
do with GitGat.
Oh, and one other thing that I can
mention is that I wrote a course about
GitGat for the Linux Foundation.
So everything that we're covering on this demonstration,
you can check out on that course for
free because, you know, Linux Foundation courses are
free.
And, you know, like I said, even if
you don't want to end up using GitKat
for whatever reason, learning about GitHub security posture
is great.
Eventually,
the more, you know, contributors
we get to the to the repository, eventually,
other than GitHub, we'll be able to add
additional SCM systems to it.
GitLab is almost completely ready.
Currently, it's in the testing phase.
I'm hoping that GitLab will be ready within
a week or so. And once it is,
I'll add it to the documentation
on the repository, and GitLab users will be
able to use GitHub just like GitHub users
right now.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing all that. And
I I think that
I don't know. Not not me it's not
amusing. That's the wrong word. But so many
security companies and products and even the awareness
of supply chain security over the last three
years,
all the origin stories are the SolarWinds hack.
Like, it just you know, I do a
lot of reviews for CFPs at KubeCon. Mhmm.
And, like, ever since the SolarWinds attack, it's
been supply chain supply chain. And I think
we're now at, like, peak. This is where
everybody is really starting to take security and
their security posture a lot more seriously, which
is a fantastic thing. Well, there's a lot
there's a lot of other security breaches. It's
just that SolarWind is like the poster child.
It's the most well known. So if I
say, for example, Code Cove or Argo CD
or some other names,
it's it wouldn't resonate as much because most
people wouldn't know about them. But SolarWinds, almost
everybody heard about it because it was such
a big deal at the time.
So, yeah, it's it's the poster child for
software supply chain.
Yeah. And last pass could be the poster
child for something else, but I'm not gonna
say that word on air. So
we got some love in the chat from
James for the logo as well. So why
don't we share my screen and get the
repository up so people can see where it's
at? And then we can talk a little
bit more about it.
So Sure. Since since
James said that the logo was fun, I
can share that our CTO's
daughter,
who's a graphic design major, designed the logo.
There we go. From the center of the
the thing there. Yeah. But it's a KitKat.
Right? But it's a green KitKat.
Is that what it's Yeah.
Actually, it says GitGat.
But yeah. It's it's it's a a play
on the KitKat. Yeah. Yeah. It's a play
on KitKat.
Nice.
So for anyone who wants to play with
KitKat in their own time, you can find
it at github.com/scrape-public/KitKat.
Mhmm. Nice.
So before we dive into the hands on
component, you know, we kind of shared kind
of what it's doing. Like,
I always ask the same question from similar,
not security based products, but developer experience products.
And it's always like, should
like, should all repositories
have GitGuard running against it? Is that something
you'd feel brave enough encouraging,
or is there a moment, an inflection point
where people should be like, oh, okay. Now
I should start taking a look at this.
Well, like I said, because you can run
it privately, nobody gets to see the results
other than you.
And, again, this is more useful for organization
rather than private
GitHub users. But if you have an organization,
several repositories,
you you you're working with teams, you're working
with collaborators,
sure. Run the report once a week, once
a month, once a day. Doesn't matter. The
report essentially
produces a JSON, an XML, or a gist
file.
Look at it if you want to. If
you don't, at least if something happens, you'll
be able to go back and look at
it and see where something went wrong. Even
if you don't use the state,
you'll just get the same report every time.
At least if something happens, you'll be able
to know about it. So I don't see
any problem with
either running it directly from
an image or downloading it or, you know,
forking it and running it yourself. There's lots
of options. Because it's private, I don't really
see a problem with it.
Okay. And is that something that organizations
run once and they're done, or is this
something we expect them to run at a
regular cadence?
Because of the the state that we included,
running it continuously is in encouraged.
I know because I I spoke to somebody
in check marks that at least one department
is running it continuously
at least once a week.
Yeah. That that that was the intended idea.
Just like with a lot of other security
tools,
running it once and being done with it
doesn't really help. Whatever
point at whatever point in time you're running
it, you might miss something. Only if you
run the test continuously can you see changes
or modifications
and you risk
less about missing something that happened.
Awesome.
Alright. I think we're about ready to start
getting hands on and showing people what they
can do with KitKat. But before I do,
I'll I'll pop James's comment on the screen.
He has informed us that in Japan, you
can buy a green with Zabi KitKat. So
there you go. Never been to Japan, but
it's on my list.
Cool.
To get started, the step one, according to
the the readme documentation here on the repository
is that I should go and get myself
a GitHub personal access token,
and it requires some permissions,
the ability to read the organization user
and
public keys,
repository status, deployments, repo hooks, public repo, I
guess. So nothing Mhmm. Nothing frightening. I'm not
I'm not scared of that. Yeah. I should
also say that GitGat, because I haven't mentioned
it before,
GitGat is written in in Regal with OPA.
Essentially, we're using the GitHub at least in
this instance, we're using the GitHub API to
gather information. All the information that GitGat is
using is meta information that is available through
the API,
and we're using
OPA
queries
to get the information that we need or
or actually that GitGap needs to generate the
report. So it it it doesn't actually look
into your code. It doesn't look into anything
that you might be worried about sharing.
All the permissions that GitGap requires
are, like you saw, essentially read
reading
permissions except for gist,
and we include a gist so that you
can get the report not just as a
JSON, but you can have it sent immediately
to your gist. And if you're not familiar
with gist, I'll show you where it is
in a second.
And it's much easier for most users to
look at the report in the gist and
as a JSON file.
Alright.
So we need to talk in and I'm
curious if I can do this from
the g h command line. I've never tried
it before.
I have the the full path of creating
it with the UI, but you're welcome to
try it anyway you want.
Yeah. Let's see.
I'll print the off talking GitHub. Oh, no.
No. Okay. We don't want that. Alright. I'll
just do it for the guy.
Alright. So
but I should probably keep that up. Right?
Oh,
come on, browser. There we go.
Because I need to see the permissions.
We're gonna go to settings,
developer settings.
And can it be one of the new
scoped tokens or does it have to be
a classic? I guess the scope to stay
in based on No. It doesn't really matter.
Essentially, you're you're going to look for a
personal access token. That's that's what you're looking
for.
And I see that you will have, just
like me, a two
factor authentication,
which is good. It's one of the things
that, GitGuard is checking.
Alright. And it will inspire us
seven days, so they'll hopefully sooner.
And public repositories read only or all repositories,
I guess. We're fine.
And we need
status.
Maybe I should have done this a classic
way because I don't know if these match
up. Yeah. I I don't know this much
up either. I I it's it's too new.
I always did it the classic way. Yeah.
I I don't feel brave enough to try
to do that live on the stream. So
let's just expire this instead of this. But
Yeah. I'm gonna expire tomorrow.
Yeah. Tomorrow because, you know, we don't want
anybody seeing this to get permissions
to your GitHub account. I again, you don't
need all of it. No. No. No. No.
You you marked all of it. You don't
need all of it. Oyman.
You also need the third one, public.
Yeah.
K.
We need
user.
Just is right above that. Yep. Just is
right over there. Yep. There it is. And
admin
redark
and public key. Yeah.
I don't let's see.
+1, 236.
You need to have 8. Make sure you
have 8 because I can't I can't really
see clearly. Alright. +1, 24567.
You're still missing one.
Yeah. You're missing one.
Status.
No. No. We have status.
Which one are you missing?
Makes it a little There
we go.
There it is. Yep.
Okay. So now that you have all of
them
yeah. And you need to copy it, of
course. Make sure you have it somewhere accessible
because, hopefully, we'll get to
running it continuously later, and we're going to
need it.
Now that you have it yeah.
DH token. There it is. Awesome.
Now the easiest way the easiest way to
run
git get is by using the Docker image.
You can just copy the
the line
from the
from the documentation.
Docker run g h tokens, Stripe security, giddyup
latest, data g h post gist. The post
gist means that the report
will be
immediately
exported to your gist.
Now depending on how
big and complex your GitHub account is or,
you know, whatever it is connected to, it
might take thirty seconds or so to to
finish the report.
If everything works fine, you should get the
results of 201201
created, and everything will be fine. And then
we'll go to the gists and
look at the report you got. So just
to clarify what happens and Mhmm. My OCD
will
never let me get away because no to
go to her commands. So
is it this is going to use my
GitHub token, and it's going to scan
my my whole account. It's not, like, a
single repository. It's not a single team. It's
not a single organization. It's whatever I have
access. Okay. Yep. Now, again, it's it's not
mandatory.
Obviously, you can limit the the report to
a single repository or a single whatever, but
that's slightly more fine grained. And as a
beginning, as the simplest thing you can do
to get the report
is is to run it this way and
see whatever it is you're you're you're doing.
Obviously, because this is private or at least
that's usually private when you're not doing it
live on YouTube or LinkedIn,
you want to see everything that you're connected
to, whatever teams or or collaborators
or
public
repositories that you forgot about that that you
have somewhere.
Okay.
Is that it? It's it's finished? Unable to
find no. It's not usually. Unable to find
image.
I have not
encountered that. I then pulled it, and we
got empty premises at the end. I think
it it just finished. Right? Well, if it's
finished, then we can go back to your
GitHub and look at your gists and see
if we got the report.
I think the last one is some rust,
so I don't think
Yeah. We got a report. See it here.
Can you run it again? I I don't
know why it wouldn't work because I ran
it just before we started, and it went
just fine.
You don't need to to download the
the image just to run it through your
Docker.
That's weird.
Well, we can always try running it
locally
just to see
just to see if we can get the
the JSON file and not the gist.
That's the second thing we can try. Okay.
So what I write Just a second. Yeah.
Sure. Just a second.
Eval, get get latest.
I hope I didn't miss any permissions.
I don't think so. You you get every
all the permissions that you needed to.
Let me just remove here.
JSON file.
I'm just making sure I didn't miss anything,
so I'm I'm looking at the the commands
that I ran
before we started.
And just to make sure that everything is
exactly the same, I'm going to send that
command over to you. There it is. Let's
run minus e g h token, swipe security
get latest to data g h eval.
Let's try to eval that. Yeah.
That should give you
the report
It's taking longer. On
the screen. Yeah. That should give you the
the JSON report immediately on the screen so
that at least you can see that it's
working.
Yeah. It's definitely doing something this time, which
is good.
Yeah. And if if we need to, we
can always I can always share my screen
and show the the gist report just because
I
want people to be able to see it.
And I don't have any embarrassing secrets on
my GitHub account that people shouldn't see. No.
Of course, I do, but, you know, I
don't mind sharing.
Because I wasn't always into in insecurity,
and some of my very, very old
repositories
have embarrassing
stuff in them.
So I guess You you I must have,
like, get have a. Yeah.
You you probably do.
I've been an open source contributor for about
sixteen years, so probably Yeah. Then you probably.
I I know that one of the reasons
I can share
my screen and show my account is because
other than my private account,
I'm also
I also got this
Scribe demo account in which I'm an admin.
And I'm also a member
of the Scribe you know, the usual account
of of Scribe, which is
usually, most of it is private. But because
mister
permissions to all of them, GitKat scans all
of them. So it wouldn't just tell me
if there are, for example,
too many admins in my own repository. It
would also check
the the scribe demo, and it would also
check scribe the the regular scribe as it
were, scribe public.
Because I don't want people to be staring
at a blank screen,
how about I just open the
share my screen and show
the
the reports?
Yeah. Go for it.
Just because, you know, I don't know how
long this will take, and it just feels
yeah. Okay. Share.
Can you see my screen?
Let me just click a few magic buttons,
swap the scene over, and now, yes, we
see get get account security audits.
Awesome.
So what you can see at the top
here is report.JSON.
I know it's a very imaginative name. So
if you really want to look at the
JSON, can copy it, look at it, you
know, whatever you need to if a JSON
really speaks to you and then you're more
comfortable looking at that. But for most people,
I imagine that a gist will be more
comfortable.
Now the report MD, which is markdown language,
is appears in your gist. To those of
you who are not familiar, in order to
get your gist, just go to your little
icon image, and you can see your GISTs.
Just to show you how they look, these
are all my GISTs.
You can see that I ran this earlier
today about six hours ago. Clicking here would
just get me back to the report.
Now this is the GitGat account security audit.
There's overview,
most of the stuff that it checks.
We wanted it to be, you know, clear.
So we have the motivation,
the findings,
and recommendations.
Motivation would usually explain what it is we're
checking and why. Findings are the actual, you
know, information. And recommendations is useful because if
there's
activities that you need to do or are
recommended to do, you can just do them
using the links. So let's take a look
at what GitGad is looking at. First of
all, public access.
Very easy to know that or at least
most people know when you create a repository
on on GitHub, it can either be public
or private. If it's private, you're the only
one who has access to it. It's not
visible
online. Nobody sees it. Nobody knows about it.
But if it's public,
everybody can see it. Even if you didn't
tell anybody
and it's public, it's still visible online, and
if people can search for it, people can
find it,
and people can essentially look at the code,
fork it, do whatever they want with it.
Now this one tells me that I have
30 repositories that are public. It says 30
out of 30 just because it doesn't see
my private ones, and there are a few
private ones.
So I have 30 repositories
that are public. Now the interesting thing that
you can see here is that it checks
mister b lightning, which is me on GitHub.
It also checks scribe demo, and it also
checks scribe public
and scribe security. So it checks everything that
I'm somehow
connected with, not just, you know, me.
And it tells me that if I want
to change
public
repositories to private, all I need to do
is go for one of these links. And
let's click on this one just as an
example. Takes me to this repository, which is
I feel you build. And if I wanna
change the
the visibility, I just go to the danger
zone. It's
Let's get through this. Two factor authentication,
extremely important.
If you use two factor authentication,
people would have a slightly harder time
breaking into your account, stealing things, changing things.
We want to make it as difficult as
possible for people to do bad things in
your account. Now it's not just about you
personally. If you have an organizational account,
the peep the person controlling that account can
essentially force
everybody on that organization to use two factor
authentication.
The key finding here is that no organization
has members with two factor authentication disabled,
which is a convoluted way to say
that all the people, it is access to
checking.
What was that?
That was a motor breaker. I saved my
window. Sorry.
Okay. Sounded ominous.
It's a convoluted way of saying that everybody
has two factor authentication enabled,
and all organizations have overall enforcement, which is
good. The recommendation is is pretty much the
same.
It tells you where to go in order
to set up
your
organizational
two factor authentication or your private one if
you are not an organization.
Since the link is right there and you
can read about two factor authentication just on
GitHub documentation,
I'm not gonna, you know, explain too much
about it. Admin permissions, very simple.
Admins have extensive permissions on GitHub, so you
want to keep the admin number
as small as possible, the the minimum that
is actually required. There's a lot of organizations
in which people, if they have a problem
on GitHub, we just give the the IT
department, we just give them admin permissions to
get over whatever problem it is, which is
wrong because admins have, like I said, extensive
permissions. They can do bad bad things if
unchecked.
It actually shows that on Scribe demo, there
are three admins. On Scribe security, there are
seven. And on Scribe security test, there are
three. Notice that mister b Lightning, which is
me personally,
is not actually represented here because it's a
private account
or actually it's not an organization.
And it this this the admin permissions is
only relevant for organizations because, obviously,
if if I'm the only person
that is representing mister b lightning, there's no
point in checking the number of admins. It's
not really relevant.
And like I said, the the recommendation is
to have the bare minimum, the the only
the actual people who need that level of
permission
added.
The next thing that GitGuard is checking is
teams.
The idea is
to, again, make sure that team members have
only the permissions
and the the the access
level that they need, nothing beyond that.
Because team members can sometimes change teams or
get shuffled around,
It's not people don't always make sure to
to
curb
excess access.
I know it's like a complicated sentence. The
idea here is that if a team member
changes team and needs to work on different
repositories or suddenly has a different job, make
sure that their access level is changed accordingly.
Again, this is more relevant, obviously, for organizational
accounts than private ones.
Collaborators is pretty much the same. You need
to check your collaborators, make sure that if
a person is no longer a collaborator,
you should revoke their access.
Branch protection is probably the most comprehensive thing
that we can cover. I'm not going to
go too far into it, but I will
show you what that means.
Notice here that there are 92 branches that
are lacking any protection rules.
If you're not familiar with GitHub's branch protection
rules, we'll take a look right here at
what they look like.
Branch protection rules are one of GitHub's
best way of protecting
branches.
Obviously, the most important branch you wanna protect
is main. So, you know, if you can
just add the main name here. The things
you can do with branch protection rules are
require pull request before merging, require status checks
to pass,
require conversation resolution,
require signed commits. Very, very important to help
prevent fraud because, you know, unless you know,
in case you didn't know, anybody can appear
to be anybody else on GitHub. All you
need is their username and email, and you
can appear to be somebody else. Just like
you can appear to be anybody else on
Slack. Again, very common. If you didn't know,
check it out. It's frighteningly
easy
to impersonate other people on GitHub unless you
use signed commits.
Require linear history, require deployments to succeed. There's
a whole bunch of rules here, including preventing
admins from being able to circumvent these rules.
Also, you know, very useful. And just like
you can protect
main, there are also other branches you want
want you might want to protect, but this
is up to you.
Notice that the reports
only checks if there
branch protection rules,
any rules. It doesn't check for the presence
of all of them or even some of
them. So even if you have a branch
protected by one single rule, whichever,
it would already could be considered protected. It's
completely up to you. But having main particularly
main branches without any protection
is probably
not the best idea. And notice there are
92 branches
that I personally have never bothered protecting on
my personal account
because I'm an Audible.
Signed commits, I already mentioned, and it's so
so important that we figured we wanted to
check that separately.
Deploy keys
and SSH keys are both very important because
they enable
external
applications to access your GitHub account. So you
wanna make sure that you revoke them
over time, that you rotate them over time.
And, again, I I don't wanna go too
deeply into this because you can always check
it out later. Just know that this is
part of the report. So even if you
forgot about some deploy key or SSH key
that you previously set up for whatever reason,
this will remind you of it. So we're
already about half an hour in,
and I showed you
a lot of the reports.
And I think, you know, even if you
had no idea what you could use this
for, you can see that it's incredibly fine
grained.
And the fact that there are links here
to enable you to go exactly to where
you need to go to do what you
would theoretically want to do with
and and learn about it is quite useful.
And, again, the fact that it appears in
the gist is also quite useful.
And if you wanna use
the the JSON for a machine readable file
to send it wherever, you can also do
that. So this is the basic level
of the GitHub
currently, GitHub security posture report.
Like I said, more relevant to organizational
accounts than private accounts, but even if you're
a private account, you can still learn something.
For example, even if you, for for example,
were a collaborator or have some access to
some organization, you'll be able to see the
information on that as well as as as
far as it pertains
to you or, you know, the the things
that you have access to.
I
will now stop sharing so we can go
back to seeing
where you are.
So
Let's see if that report finished.
It did finish. I even ran it again
and put it through JQ so we could
get better color as well. So
we have
Okay. Lots.
Yeah.
Yep. It's chunky. And and and yeah. You
can see yeah. You can see that seeing
it as a
as a JSON is definitely not as
user friendly.
You can learn a lot from the JSON.
Obviously, there's a lot of information there.
It's just not as
readable,
at least not immediately. If you're experienced, you
can definitely
read it pretty easily. But I believe that
the gist
solution is is quite handy. That's why I
requested it so that anybody can look at
the at the markdown report and and be
able to immediately
understand what was happening even if they didn't
have any
too heavily
developing background that are not that familiar with
reading JSON files.
So like I said, this is the basic
level, the the easiest, most immediate thing that
you can do with GitGat. It doesn't require
almost anything other than having
the token which you created for it. You
know, handily, it didn't even take you five
minutes. And running the report, again, it could
take longer depending on how complicated your GitHub
account is, but it's not no. It it
doesn't take minutes or hours to run the
report. And now that you have this JSON
file, you can keep it and use it
as a reference to,
you know, what happens in your account over
time.
Sure. Now that we said over time,
let's
jump.
Yeah.
Well, I don't know if you're about to
go into something I was about to ask
you ask you about. Yeah. Sorry.
Don't know. It's Sure. Ask ask ask away.
I think my latency is is bad today.
I'm not sure what's going on. Like, even
my camera, I can see myself lagging behind.
Anyway, we're not gonna worry about that.
You know, the
JSON
is great. Right? So I I don't have
kind of machine programmatic access to be able
to do things with this that that I
want, which I think is really interesting. The
guest is just sorry. It's even it's much
more consumable
for humans. And then you mentioned over time,
which is great because the thing I was
thinking about as well. If I run this,
say every day, every week, every month, whatever
that cadence is going to be, is that
I'm gonna wanna track improvement. It's like, we
have the ability
is is any of this exported as metrics?
Like, could I build a Grafana previous dashboard
from some of this information? Is that something
that's possible today?
You could definitely do that as long as
you, you know, as long as you have
access to the information,
which is why the next part of running
it continuously requires you to
fork
GitGap, putting it on your personal GitHub account,
and then using
a workflow to run it continuously, which is
what we're going to do now to show
how easy it is. And, obviously, once you
have
a workflow and GitGat in as part of
your GitHub, you can do whatever you want
with the information.
You can
export the files. You can save them in
in
either on GitHub or on your own machine.
Do whatever you want with them.
But what again, once you have it on
your own GitHub and you start working with
the workflow and with the state, which is
where we're going to get to the state
later
after I explain how to run it continuously,
you'll see that, like you said, there's a
lot more options
and a lot you can play with.
Let's start with showing you how to run
it continuously because I feel like it's an
important
advancement
over running it once, seeing the report saying,
hey. That's cool, and then forgetting about it.
So let's let's see how to run it
continuously.
So
fork GitGat over to your GitHub.
Alright.
And should I run it on the organization?
Again, as long sure. Sure.
It doesn't it doesn't really matter as long
as it's on your GitHub. Because remember,
you already created an access token, and we're
going to use that access token
in
your, essentially, copy of GitGat.
So now that you have GitGat as part
of Rawkode Academy,
yep, you go to settings.
I'm assuming we're adding Settings and then essentially,
yeah,
essentially, you're you're adding
a new
a new repository secret.
So is this some like, when you run
a GitHub action, you actually get
ephemeral
GitHub
token available and you can tweak the permissions
inside of the the run. But I I
don't know if that's scoped purely to, like,
the repository itself or if you can elevate
it to the organization.
But that that could be something fun to
experiment with as well, actually. Like I said,
you can actually run the report
on a particular repository
or even if you want to, one particular
folder or or particular
files.
But I feel like that it's more
useful to run it over an entire organization
unless
once I, you know, introduce you to the
idea of state, unless the state
is significantly
different enough between different repositories
that you wanna have a different report for
each repository,
and you can do that. You can you
can
have
separate workflows running, get the a different GitKat
report on different repositories with different states,
Slightly more work intensive to do or to
set up, but once you set it up,
it would continuously
run however you set it up, and you
can always modify the state to get whatever
results you're you're after. But we haven't gotten
into state yet, So let's concentrate
on getting this to work. You already set
up the the g h token.
Yep. So now
or I believe you did. I I might
have missed it because I was talking.
Now that you did, you go to actions.
In the the token, you you copied the
the same token you had earlier. Right? That's
correct. Yeah.
Great. That's exactly the token you needed. So
now you go into
actions.
Not not here. No. On the top. On
the top line, there's actions there. Yep. That's
the one.
Yep. You understand.
Right. Now on the left side,
continuously run GitGap.
Now the first time you run it, it'll
just, you know, just to see that you've
run it, that everything is fine. You can
see on the right there, run
the workflow.
Yep. Run it.
So now it's running. And, you know, like
we saw earlier, it might take a while,
but because you now have it as a
as a workflow there, now it's running,
it will take as as much time as
as needed. But now that you have it
as part of a workflow,
you can well, obviously, now it's running once.
But if you want to,
you can
set it up as a Chrome job. So
in order to set up currently
and the easiest way to do this as
as something that runs continuously, you go to
code.
I see that it didn't finish for whatever
reason, but we can worry about that later.
Go to code,
which is the
leftmost
marker there.
Yeah. And the top folder is now
GitHub workflows.
And the top one is right. Yep.
And you can see
that in order to make this run continuously,
all you have to do is remove the
commenting on the those two lines. Not the
top one because
it tells you to, you know, remove the
next two. Right?
And if you remove the commenting on the
schedule
and
yeah. Essentially, you run every 23.
Now this, again, it's we try to make
it as easy, as simple as possible for
people to who didn't understand too much about
this to do this relatively easily.
If you are not
familiar with
Chrome or how to set up
Chrome jobs and stuff like that, I'm now
sending a link to David, and and hopefully,
he can show it on screen
that you can essentially use that link just
to specify
whatever
iteration you want,
and it will show you how to
specify that
in a Chrome, you know, manner.
You can set up the you can you
can tell it to to run at a
specific date, specific time, every so and so
time. There this
is just one that I found. I'm sure
there are others either more useful or or
more fun or whatever. But even if you
have absolutely no idea about how to set
up a Cron job, you can find one
of these sites or this one
and and figure out the
the iteration that you wanted to run it.
And now that you have that, you essentially
have a way of running GitGat continuously.
Once it's it is done continuously, you will
always get the the results
presumably in your gist if you set it
up that way.
And, also, it enables you to start working
with a state. Now before we go into
a state,
any questions so far?
No. I think I understand what's happening.
I'm curious of why
my run failed.
It didn't it didn't yeah.
Yeah. I can't really see it clearly enough
to be able to tell. Yeah. There's no
error message. It just says process completed with
exit code 125.
But there's no error message. I
can
yeah. I'll I'll ask the developer
who
who wrote it what 125 is.
Since, like I said, I didn't write the
code myself, since I didn't, I don't really
remember
what 125 is, but I can definitely ask.
And we can add it as a comment
once the
the stream is is done
because I don't know if he's available right
now. In case, you know, our viewers are
not aware, it is now about 07:00 in
the evening where I am, so most people
are no longer at the office or available.
Okay. So But, yeah, we we try to
variable possible
to for for new people to
mhmm.
So and Again, I can't see the the
the screen clearly.
Yeah.
Variable inside of the GitHub action is GitHub
secret rather than g h token.
Well, let's let's see if I can fix
this. It should be g h token. Sure.
I I I ran it like I said,
I ran it everything earlier
and it seemed to have worked fine. I
don't know why it didn't. Okay. Can't rename
them. Okay. Let's add a new one. You
can create a new one. Yeah.
GitHub
secret.
And is it still on my buffer?
No.
Let me grab that from up here.
I don't know why I'm hiding it. I
mean, I'm done this pasting directly in front
of everybody. We already showed it. Yeah. We
already showed it.
Like, I I highly recommend you disable it
as soon as the stream is done. Oh,
we can't start it. It's GitHub.
Let's check out this actually. You just go
to actions. Yeah.
You just go to actions and run it
again. You can always go to actions. Oh,
alright. Okay. Yeah. The
g h secret, not g h token. Okay.
Now we're okay. Now I can fix this.
Yeah. Okay.
But you probably told me to do that,
and I probably just I I yeah. It
was supposed to be the yeah. Like
I said, I'm I'm looking at several things
at the same time, so must have missed
it. Alright. So let's run that again.
Yeah. It's Yeah.
And this triggered the manual
run. Yeah. Mhmm.
And we'll give that just a moment. So
hopefully that runs a bit better. But maybe,
well, that does hopefully run. You can tell
us a little bit about
state.
Sure. Sure. I would love to.
Okay. The idea behind state
is
we wanted to enable people
to tell the report
what they're interested in,
what things they no longer want to hear
about because they're fine,
and being able to tell the report essentially
various things that they want to pay particular
attention to. What does that mean? Well, let's
say let's take the the my report that
I showed you earlier as an example.
It said that there are 30 repositories
that are
currently public.
Let's say that this is the fifth time
I'm getting the report, and it keeps telling
me the exact same thing. Now I know
about these third wave repositories. I know they're
public. I'm fine with the fact that they're
public. If I don't wanna get the same
notification again, all I can say well, I
can go to the state and set up
these repositories
as public,
And, essentially, everything in the state is fine.
It's it's how it's supposed to be. So
it wouldn't alert me once again to things
that I've already told them is fine. Now
it's particularly
relevant if you're in a big organization and
you have not a couple of dozen repositories,
but a couple hundreds or more repositories and
you have hunt potentially hundreds of people, including
collaborators,
including teams,
including admins,
and going over all the information all the
time is extremely tiring. I see that the
report finished successfully this time.
So the idea is, again, once you get
the report and you check everything,
you fix whatever you wanted to fix, and
you have a basic state
of, you know, your
security posture that you want to keep it
that way. You put everything in the state,
which you can do because,
essentially, the state is just a JSON file,
and you can copy
the things that you want into it from
the report that you got as a JSON.
Once you put the stuff in the state,
which, you know, I'll I'll show you some
of the basic stuff later,
once you copy stuff into the state, all
the stuff that is in there, you will
no longer get in the report. It's fine.
That means that once you set up the
state and you run the report continuously,
all the the only things you will get
are the deltas.
What is different
from the state? Let's say you added more
repositories,
added more team members, more admins,
people that have somehow failed, disabled
their multifactor authentication,
disabled their signed commits, various things
that are new.
That makes the report a lot shorter and
a lot easier to work with than seeing
a gigantic organizational
GitHub account
report every single time. So the first thing
that the state is for is to enable
you to work,
you know, make your work a lot easier.
And the second thing is to use it
to set up specific
use cases, but, you know, we'll get to
that possibly later.
So let's now that I, you know, basically
explained what the state is and because the
report has run successfully and you've set up
the cron job to make it run every
twenty three hours currently, which is fine,
let's talk a little bit about the state
or, you know, where to
find it, where to play with it.
So
if you will look in your
GitHub account
or should should I say GitGat, actually,
you will notice you can just go back
to code.
Yeah. You will notice a folder called data.
Yep.
But in data right now,
there are two files.
One is an empty input.
Essentially,
you know, that's an example file that you
can use,
rename, use what however you want as as
some sort of input file. We'll get to
the input later, and
there is a sample
input.
Now the sample input is there to show
you
various things that you could
theoretically
put in an input file and how they
would look. Let's open that and just, you
know, take a look at it for a
second.
Again, a JSON file.
You can see by the let me just
open it on my screen because, like I
said, I can't really look at it on
yours. Just a second.
Got the workflows. I'm going to
get to
data
to the sample input. Yeah.
Obviously, the first line that you see is
token.
It just makes it easier. You no longer
if you include that here and g h
token has been, you know, defined, you no
longer have to put the the g h
token every time you you run the report.
Organizations,
you can set up whichever organizations you want
the report to be running on. You don't
have to include all of them in case
you are a member or running several organizations.
Two factor authentication,
admins,
commits,
a lot of the stuff here is essentially
exactly the same as what we saw in
the gist report.
So the the naming
conventions is pretty pretty standard, pretty easy to
follow.
One of the things that I can show
you, for example, is if you go slightly
lower, you can see files
with permissions.
This will enable you if you want to
set up particular files which have particular
permissions
as in if somebody who is not supposed
to handle those particular files or repositories,
the report will alert to it. One of
the things that I I really need to
to stress here is that GitKat, because it
it's a read only report and it's a
report only,
it can't do anything. It can't stop, for
example, an admin
from accessing something. It can't really, you know,
make any sort of of stance on on
protecting
anything. The only thing it can do is
note when something that you didn't want happen
happen and,
you know, tell you about it in the
report. Now assuming you're running the report every
day,
let's say somebody with admin access touched something
they're not supposed to, the very next day,
you'll get that in the report.
So
that's a useful thing to have. Even if
you couldn't stop it, at least you know
about it.
You have hooks here. You have teams. You
have branches.
Once again, you can you can
set particular branches to be slightly more protected
than others.
There's a lot of stuff here, but because
this is an example,
you can essentially look at it and and
figure out how your input file
should look if you want to to do
something specific.
You can just play with it, run the
report, see what you get,
you know, if if you want to.
One of the things that I can
show you as an example
and, again, I can I can show this
to you, but, you know, running it will
not really be
that effective because, you know, it it depends
on the the initial report that I ran
for myself?
Let's say that
Inscribe demo,
which is one of the organizations that I'm
in charge of because it's a demo, there
was a user
who didn't have two factor authentication
for whatever reason.
But
that user, which I happen to know,
is is located in a different country, and
it doesn't have two factor authentication
for a good reason. There's a problem with
the network. It didn't work. Whatever. It needed
to be able to access
the organizational
GitHub without two factor authentication.
Now I didn't want
to get
the reports telling me every single time that
user was problematic.
So
what I would do
let me just
write essentially, I I would write it
in your in the
in the chat, and, hopefully, you can
show that. Actually, you know what? No. I
can just show it by sharing my screen.
Yeah. That would be simpler.
Okay.
There it is. Okay.
So this is the example I was talking
about. Obviously, the first line is token,
which is, in our case, g h token.
And in order to make sure that this
weak authenticated user, which is the example user
I was talking about, wasn't popping up on
the report every single time,
I would include TFA,
disabled members, scribe demo, this user. Now the
fact that this user is now included in
the TFA
or two factor authentication
list or or essentially, you know, TFA
section of the report means that when the
report shows that this particular user doesn't have
2FA, because it's part of the state,
he would no longer be included in the
report. This the the the state says, it's
fine. I know about it. I accepted it.
I wrote it. It's fine. I I don't
I no longer need to be alerted to
this fact every single time.
It's fine.
There are other examples that we can
like, I think I can show you. Let
me roll down a little bit. No. That
that's, like, a very, very simplified example
that shows
shows what it can do. I think that
I have a better example
a little later.
Yeah. Now remember I said that we can
protect
particular files.
So this is the example for that,
for a file level permission.
In files,
permissions
in this particular
repository,
the README
MD file
can be accessed by these author authors and
these committers.
Essentially,
both these are
an array, so I can have this as
a as a, you know, as many as
I want. But that means that if a
different author or a different committer than the
ones written in my list have done anything
to this file,
my report will tell me about it. So
this is a way for me to protect
particular files in particular repositories
from
unwanted access. Now, again, when I say protect,
just means I'll be alerted to it. I'll
know about it. I can't really stop
people who have legitimate access,
but I can
make sure that I know about it.
I think this is one of the better
examples for fine grained file protection that you
can set up using GitKat.
GitHub itself doesn't really enable you to do
this, but GitKat
does.
Nice.
Any questions
any questions so far?
No. I think a lot of this is
making sense. I love the fact that we
can
kind of put all this together, get the
report, monitor things, continue to improve. You know,
it's not all about finding a silver bullet
with security. It's all about continuous improvement and
making sure that whatever we have today was
better than yesterday.
The only thing that's really kind of floating
around my head is that, you know, you
said all of this is written on Regal.
Like, what if I wanted to contribute my
own policies or have my own private policies?
Is this something
that is possible?
Of course, is. Yeah. Just now, you essentially
forged Git Gat. It is now
essentially
yours to play with as you want.
One of the the chapters which I've added
to the
Linux Foundation
course, which I mentioned
and actually, because
I wanted to make sure that our viewers
have
the link if they want to,
I'll now share the link with you so
you can show it on screen
just because, you know,
I you can consider it a cheat sheet
for GitGat having the course,
you know, available. It's free. There's absolutely no
reason not to
look at it. So
Linux Foundation
one two two x is the name of
the course or, you know, their name for
it. It's GitHub Supply Chain Security using GitGap.
The final chapter
is how to add additional
queries
to the report.
Now I know that most people or at
least most of our viewers would not be
familiar with OPA
or with Regal,
which is fine.
The the chapter assumes that you don't have
that much information about either Rigo or OPA,
but you do have some,
not a lot, some understanding
of how to code. It shows you what
you need to do, where you need to
do it. And because everything is reliant on
GitHub API,
at least as much as, you know, we're
we're talking about GitHub
security posture right now,
so we are using the GitHub API,
In order to look at the GitHub API,
see what you need to get, it's it's
very simple. GitHub has very handy API links.
So you figure out what what you wanna
ask the API, you figure out the information
you want from it, and the how to
essentially,
the example is how to add it as
a query.
The query that
we're the the last
chapter
of the course is adding
is how to
make or or add different organization, get essentially
a list of the organizations
that you are a member of
separately,
just as an example, obviously.
But just like you can do that, you
can essentially play with it to have your
own
queries, your own information.
Obviously, would be happy to you know, once
you figure out a query,
you can just add it, send the PR
or or, you know, do a PR to
the actual
scribe GitGat, and we'll be happy to add
it so that everybody can use it.
Like I mentioned earlier, GitLab is just on
the verge of being added.
Obviously, it will be slightly different. It will
be more of GitLab than GitHub.
Eventually,
we're hoping to add
all the other SCMs as well.
The more people play with this, the more
people add queries and useful information,
the better it'll be for everybody. And even
if you choose not to share whatever queries
you develop yourself with everybody, the fact that
you can custom
fit
the state and the input to exactly what
it is you need, what your organizational
requirements are,
I think, essentially means that you can take
it yet and make it your own tool.
You take the basic, you know, package that
we created and you make it your own.
You can you know, even if
you're fine with people not using two f
a, you're fine with every single one of
your users being admin,
you're fine with nobody using signed commits, if
you're fine with it, just put it in
the input.
The report will no longer, you know, bother
you about it.
Just, you know, as long as you are
aware
of the ramifications
of your actions and your choices,
it's your repository. Do whatever you want with
it.
Alright.
I guess, again, a final question for me
is, like, is get get done?
Like, what what's on the road map?
No.
No. No. No. Like I said,
the the the next
closest thing within, like, let's say, a week
or so is adding GitLab
almost completely ready,
and
it's in testing right now. Once it's done,
I'll update the documentation
so that people who use GitLab
would know how to use it essentially just
as easily as people who use GitHub right
now can.
Obviously, GitLab is slightly different slightly different
UI. So I'll make sure that everything I
write is is just as clear.
After that, there are other SCMs.
And once we're done with
we're actually in parallel with adding
additional SCMs,
we're constant queries because there are other things
that the
GitHub API
can allow us to
check,
and there's more things that we want to
be able to show people. This is essentially,
like, this when we built it, this was
our basic list,
stuff that we absolutely
wanted or had to show people, especially, for
example, the branch protection rules, which definitely not
enough people are familiar or aware of,
which is, I think, a very, very useful
tool by GitHub. It's a shame more people
are not aware of it.
And I'm sure GitLab
and and Bitbucket and others have other things
like that, and we wanna make sure people
know about it. And seeing it in the
report
is one of the ways to make sure
people are aware.
Essentially, the whole thing is just, you know,
make people aware
of SCM security posture,
protect your code better.
Awesome.
Is there anything else that we haven't covered
yet that you want to cover before we
finish up today?
Well, there like I said, there's a lot
of fine
fine grained, fine details that you can do
that, you know, we haven't really covered, but
I don't feel like we need to. Like,
setting up GitKid to run on a particular
repository
or a particular file, It's all in the
documentation.
I want to encourage people so I don't
wanna show everything. I want to encourage people
to go to GitGat, play with it themselves,
play with the actual code, add queries,
play with the
with the state,
and define their own
definitions
and and conditions to it just to see
what they get.
The more people play with it, the more
they make it their own, and, hopefully, we'll
get additional maintainers
for for this repository
for this project.
Awesome.
Well, thank you so much for taking time
out of your day for sitting down and
guiding us through this and for your work
on all the documentation.
I think that's gonna be really useful to
people as they start to explore and bring
get get into their organizations.
I think what I love about it is,
again, it's got this educational
aspect to it. You know, we don't often
think about our security posture outside of the
code that we write, but, you know, there's
lots of things that have to be taken
into consideration.
And, you know, something like branch protection, you're
right. It's like just one of those features
is right there staring you in the face
and yet most of the time we rarely
turn that on. And I think just having
something we can stick in the GitHub action,
let it just run and get a report
once a week or whenever. But just as,
hey, you've still not changed the branch protection
rules. You're still not unable to FA for
the issues or you're still having
random interns right to your production environment fail.
Like, these are things you don't want to
happen and until you have that constant nagging
thing on your shoulder. Not that get guys
nagging, but you have that awareness. Right?
You're it's it's too easy forgotten, too easy
just to sweep under the rug and we'll
get around to it later. And unfortunately, later
is never soon enough when we have malicious
hackers on the internet. So very cool to
know. Things that yeah. A couple of things,
like I said earlier, that people can easily
forget about,
SSH keys and deploy keys.
You set them up. You say Yep. Oh,
they'll set it for six months
or or, you know, a year.
That application
is no longer running after three months, but
the key is still there. If somebody who's
not approved to get access to that key,
they can have access GitHub account. You really
wanna keep on top of these keys,
and this report is one of the ways
to do that
to make sure you're not missing any keys,
you didn't forget about any keys.
You know, if if somebody for example, you
get an an alert that somebody accessed your
GitHub account, the first thing you wanna do
is make sure you disable all your keys.
Just, you know, on the off chance we
might have gotten off with one.
Nice.
Alright. Let me pop this back over to
big Facebook.
But, again, thank you so much for spending
time. If people have any questions, if you're
watching us after the fact, then links to
Twitter profiles and GitHub repositories. I'll even add
the Linux Foundation course will all be in
the description below momentarily.
Any last parts before we wrap up? Yeah.
And all all my
yeah. I think that you can also add
all the links to me. I think you
you mentioned that, but I'm I'm not sure
you did. So I'm I'm saying if you
didn't, you can add those, my email, my
LinkedIn,
my Twitter.
Feel free to to ask me anything either
about GitGat or about what Sprite Security does.
I'm the developer advocate. That's my job to
explain things. So feel free to ask.
Alright. Awesome.
Cool. Alright. Well, you have a wonderful evening.
Hopefully, speak to you again soon. And if
there's any major feature updates, if you wanna
reach back out, please feel free to anytime.
To everyone who watched, have a wonderful day,
and we'll see you all next time. Adios.
Thank you.